today on Judge Jesse judge Jesse turns
up the heat you signed a piece of paper
he gave you the snake then you bring a
snake into the home with two
with two boss I had not been made aware
that the snake would get rid of his skin
and then the sprinklers came down with
the snakeskin room on my carpet what
what set off the sprinklers unrelated
popcorn fire your honor
judge Jesse as a police officer he
defended the streets as a trial lawyer
objection he fought for the truth as a
black belt
he mastered discipline
as a carpenter he learned the value of
craftsmanship as a surgeon he mastered a
cool head
as a crack hoe he learned to go days
without sleep
and as an announcer he does the voice
over on this show